we had uh who came out oh uh The
Undertaker came out to the show last
night oh dude which is pretty crazy dude
I went to his house yes I think he Hardy
has a beautiful homie he was just
describing some of it not like in a
braggy way just saying that they lived
here he is
you talk to him for a while yeah really
nice the nicest like one of the nicest
guys I've ever met him and his wife and
she had some bangers on her and I
shouldn't say that out loud I mean this
is a damn Undertaker we're talking to
who works for death where was it is this
at the uh is that the Paramount the
Paramount yeah uh you had Ron there too
yeah it was nice man that's awesome man
that rod looks great for I mean Ron is
like
48.
I think he's a little older he looks
[__] great he looks great that head
of hair too God you almost want to
[__] scalp at me yeah you do you
might get there you might have that one
day we'll see man a full head of white
hair is pretty [__] cool dude I would
love that he is the coolest no I went
over to uh
to it's so crazy to say The Undertaker's
house and uh
and like he was like come on it it was
just to uh check out a piece of workout
equipment okay and the people that I was
talking to I was like I'd like to
they're like do you want this thing I go
I'd like to try it before I go I want
this thing yeah and then they go we
could like I have a another client that
you know I go okay
and then they just like in a text
they're like hey Tom this Mark he has it
and I was like what's up Mark
and then like a separate text came in
they're like just so you know Mark is
the Undertaker I was like oh okay good
to know uh
and then I just go over there and he
just couldn't be like more gracious we
weren't an apron and everything I mean
yeah he's like here's a muffin he was
just like no but he he was like so and
then he was just like yeah try whatever
you want like gave us like the full tour
and then he was like well it was a real
pleasure meeting you and I was like same
yeah and then later on I go thanks a lot
for uh you know allowing us and he sent
like
the the most like the most gracious text
of like uh it was a absolute pleasure to
welcome you into my home I was like oh
that's nice [__] is this man like this
is wild but death will sneak you like
that too that's what death would do
that's true it would it would kind of
taunt you yeah yeah and seduce you yeah
yeah so maybe I should watch out I mean
around Mark hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one or
this one